i want to elaborate a little bit on my
comments yesterday
about the republican party crumbling
under donald trump
and trump really losing everything for
the republican party
um with a focus not on evaluating
the virtue or morality
of any particular individual republican
because as i told you they all deserve
uh the repercussions of sticking by
trump for 99.9
of the presidency but i think that we
are going to see
a six-month period into joe biden's
transition that will really be unlike
anything we've seen before i know donald
trump often says this is like nothing
we've seen before
this really is like nothing we've seen
before we have never had a situation
where
during a global hundred year pandemic we
have
a president made a one-term president
who refuses to accept that they actually
lost
incites dozens of bogus lawsuits
and a violent riotous insurrection that
leads to
a temporary delay in the counting of the
electoral votes
gets suspended from multiple social
media networks for
um essentially praising the violence
saying the pro tea understands why the
protesters did what they did this is
what you get when you steal an election
donald trump saying on twitter before
twitter deleted that
we have never had a situation like this
and so
we are seeing mitch mcconnell the
absolutely
horrible senate majority leader lose his
position as senate majority leader
likely uh uh to um be replaced by
uh democrat chuck schumer as democrats
take control of the senate thanks to the
two runoff victories in georgia by
raphael warnock and john
ossoff on tuesday night into wednesday
morning and you also are going to see
at the same time that republicans lose
control of the senate
you see them very much on the defensive
having to either denounce or jump in
with or explain
away this riotous insurrection that took
place
on wednesday um at a time when we so
desperately need leadership
at a time when the economy is as
precarious as it's ever been
we had i i wondered six days ago
will we get to 4 000 coronavirus deaths
a day well on wednesday we had 4 100.
as the violent insurrection was taking
place
and donald trump was getting banned from
twitter and facebook as all that was
going on
we passed for the first time 4 000
coronavirus dead in one day in fact the
number i believe was was 4 100.
so what is going to be the role of the
republican party
in the next two years what is going to
be their role
as uh we hopefully start to see
vaccination help tamp down the pandemic
in a more permanent way
are they going to do what we've
suspected for a long time
which is sort of kind of pretending they
were never really with trump even if
they were
and going back to we can't afford this
and what about the dead and we need to
be
constitutional conservatives and
financial conservatives what exactly is
going to be
their uh what exactly is going to be
their approach and on
in a very practical sense joe biden said
earlier this week
two thousand dollar stimulus checks are
riding on the georgia elections
democrats got the two georgia elections
are we getting two thousand dollar
stimulus checks now uh democrats have
control
will will have control of the house
senate and white house
and they've been talking about two
thousand dollar stimulus checks
democrats in the house and senate have
said they're okay with two thousand
dollar stimulus checks
so is that going to happen uh are we
going to see
to what degree and i i am not yet
taking a position i want to think about
it more to what degree
is a biden administration potentially
with attorney general merrick garland
and control of the house and senate to
investigate whatever the hell they want
to what degree are the trump crime
families wrongdoings
going to be investigated um there are
a lot of compelling arguments to be made
one way or another about the
investigation of former
former president in the united states
but what do that these next two years
look like
do republicans manage to become acute
obstructionists
do they sort of act like normal people
for a little bit is it conceivable and i
know this is so
it's almost naive and cliche to say but
do a few reasonable
reasonable republicans that saw the
error of trump
trump's ways like you know the
perpetually disappointed susan collins
and
mitt romney who voted to to convict on
one of the two articles of impeachment
do they join democrats in the senate
so that it's not 50 50 if joe manchin is
okay
with a tiebreaker by kamala harris but
maybe it's 52-48
on some of these key issues would susan
collins and mitt romney go for
some some you know green energy
infrastructure deal with some teeth
to it i don't know i don't know the
answers but what we do know
is that donald trump has lost everything
for the republican party
losing them the house in 2018 losing
them the senate and the white house in
2020.
the republican party in a sense is
crumbling but
we know from history is very resilient
and has voters who are very willing
to say oh trump's gone we're back to we
care about the debt and deficit and
uh blocking abortion again and you know
uh religious freedom or whatever
we know they're eager to get back to
that and so the next two years are a
real question mark i think
joe biden's first hundred days will tell
us a lot about how that's going to go
let me know what you expect i'm on
twitter at dpakman
one of our sponsors today is magic spoon
the reason i'm such a fan of magic spoon
is they allow me to enjoy the delicious
breakfast cereals i loved as a kid
without all the sugar and without the
unhealthy ingredients because magic
spoon makes breakfast cereal
that you really can't tell apart from
those tasty sugary cereals that we all
know
but each serving of magic spoon has no
sugar
three net carbs and 11 grams of protein
so it's perfect for someone on a low
carb
keto diet just anybody trying to eat
healthier and cut back on the sugar
you can choose from cocoa frosted fruity
cinnamon blueberry or peanut butter they
all taste amazing
and magic spoon now lets you create your
own customized variety pack
with the flavors you choose they really
do stand by their product and will
refund 100 percent of your money if you
don't love it
no questions asked go to magicspoon.com
pacman to build your own custom variety
box today
make sure to use promo code pacman to
get free shipping
the link is right underneath this video